então aqui é o cana brava né
o canal bravo é um lixão na bahia onde o
meu pai e minha mãe já catavam reside
muitas vezes estavam cantando no exílio
e as pessoas nem imaginava que o meu pai
minha mãe tava catando lixo da kombi não
estava cantando alguma coisa bonita eu
nasci dentro do canal aberto
eu e outro em três crianças de catadores
de catadores assim e tal então chamava
canabrava que era bom de energia então
aí eu já como criança já estava
brincando é tava cantando e brincam o
carnaval chegar os caminhos jogáveis
muitas vezes brinquedo essas coisas
quebradas
mesmo dentro de um lixão catano e com
outra experiência de catadores e
catadoras eu achava que aquele era legal
e brincadeira e lacan natal com 56 anos
já a minha dependência do álcool começou
dentro do aterro da casa branca que meu
pai minha mãe era catador e eu acabava
pegando ea vez com 56 anos é chegar no
caminho jogar um monte de resíduos e
lixo não existe eu catava aquela
embalagem mas não sabia ler que nunca
fui para a escola e nada nem sabia o que
era escola e aí às vezes aquela
embalagem não sabia ler
eu pegava uma garrafa virada estava com
fome e às vezes com conselho virava e
era um alvo por de repente podia se
ouvir um chileno que é bom né
mas aí eu virava então minha
independência com 56 anos já começou na
terça eu não mais os catadores conta
deles e aí isso aí quando o caminhão
chegava então a maioria dos nossos pais
lá quem chegar bem cedo de madrugada
para pegar o melhor caminho quero estar
no filé o filho foi o caminho que venha
mais coisas boas pra poder poder viver
já dentro do canabrava nos catadores
catadora jade explorado pelo sistema do
capital a gente sabe que esse bagulho
capital o capitalismo é uma linguagem
não sabia que estava catando lá pra
sobreviver como e aí se você pegasse é é
um quilo de latim se colocava não pagou
o pacote de arroz que você pegasse
dez quilos de papel sempre acaba tal e
muitos catadores já então chegava lá
tinham chegado de madrugada e isso é de
madrugada quando chegava os nossos pais
ele colocava algumas com a gente é
criança dentro de uma caixa para dormir
vez acaba esquecendo e muitos filhos de
catadores e catadoras acabou soterrado
ali e no sistema que jogava tudo lá e
tal e aí foi [ __ ]
eu morria tal e até hoje a gente não
sabe o que aconteceu com eles
aí o canabrava fechou fechou é uma área
de 30 mil metros quadrados e fechou com
construir no estádio lá tal felizmente
construir um estádio dentro em cima do
tempo e de repente o que pode fazer um
explodir tudo é que dentro de até você
não tá e aí o carnaval de jogo fui para
salvador onde é o adolescente sem
conhecê lo com não conheço nem meu pai
minha mãe até hoje 16 estão vivos não é
e os amigos minha família hoje pois
amigos que eu fiz na minha trajetória e
minha família que meus filhos seis
filhos e meu neto e minha companheira
qual é e aí fechou em que foi um garoto
ainda foi morar nas ruas de salvador e
de pouco depois morei dentro do orfanato
foi criado em um orfanato com a dona
margot que criava era uma senhora negra
que criava outras crianças então a gente
morava lado amargou criavam e lá eu vim
pra salvador é conhecer a realidade da
sociedade consumista que isso é péssimo
o planeta o meio ambiente no pelourinho
continue catando reside lá nas ruas tal
e dormir a casa na go foi o que eu fiz
18 anos sair do sofá natutal é continuar
em salvador catâneo coisa com o meu
carrinho da um pelourinho e ainda com a
dependência química do álbum é que tudo
que eu ganhava eu tinha que o bebê que
havia me dava uma tristeza porque não
tinha fui pai não tinha mãe não queria
saber que não sabia o que era ter um
carinho até hoje é difícil pra mim a
cara entre as três filhos e já
neto mas fui aprendendo com o tempo e aí
em salvador em melhoria contínua e
pegando materiais recicláveis e não em
salvador que é uma rua que chamava rua
do bispo [ __ ] eu nem o meu nome numa
rua que tinha menor me foi possível que
os cada reservatório esse espaço aqui
pra mim dormir porque até o meu nome por
mais em minha vida eu quero é isso não
vou continuar morando na roma já tinha
uma rua com o nome do bispo e aí em
salvador o meu primeiro carrinho eu
construí com outros catadores de
catadores
eram aquelas latas aqui em são paulo que
vocês devem chamar de concreto de 20
lippi eu cantei algumas latas daquelas e
construir um carrinho e outro grupo de
catadores começava já vender o ferro
velho ea gente já tava aquela época a
embalagem de leite divino não tinha esse
bagulho e tanto consumismo
aceleradamente que tem um sistema e
total ea gente cantava as coisas para
trocar o alimento tá e aí a gente pegava
o material e vendia lá no ferro velho de
seu joão
aí surgiu a gente chegava na balança é
uma balança na era digital de tudo
moderno tem pago digital tudo mais a
você pegava um peso e voltava 10 quilos
aqui e 10 quilômetros latina que os 10
quilos aí já na janela em forma até hoje
ano no mundo já apareceu e nós cada vez
que a tabela ainda estamos esperando até
hoje pelo sistema nem com toda essa
tecnologia por isso que a gente tem que
estudar se capacitar e entender como
funciona o processo do sistema
e aí porque o carro pagava amanhã pra
nós o quilo do ferro e um dia isso ele
levava aqueles ferro além de um corte
lula ea nicotina quando chegava a noite
ouvindo o barulho aí tem tem porque
madri lupo catar bater lá é eu via que é
do ferro mas do lado do felt o metal
ninguém sabe que mika então ele pagava
um real e vendia um centavo e vende um
réu porque tinha um metal lá aí eu falei
ou sejam já está fazendo é que aí eu
tomaria posição não pagava nem aí muito
dia chamei os catadores já falei é ele
estava pagando um preço mas é outro
ainda chegando a chamando em feijão não
vou pagar pra vocês um réu aí acho que
foi a primeira conquista nossa de cada
dia
os catadores da canabrava em salvador
que a gente né eu pagava um preço a
gente descobriu que ele vendia porque a
outra e aí até o bairro seu batista
baixo batista era um barco e tomava um
goró godoy como uma pururuca pretendia
tomar o gravador de envenenar a mesma
agulha lado neste caso e aguarda o seu
batista mangona e aí neste bairro de
chão batido em uma televisão se aquele
jorginho preto banco né meu pai nunca e
nunca tinha visto na televisão em
salvador um hater não tínhamos nada e aí
uma televisão em uma propaganda
superlegal chamou atenção na cidade de
são paulo cidade que ganha dinheiro
cidade que tem família porque bagulho
ganhar dinheiro ter família né
outro dia eu vou entrar nesse bairro uma
vez para tomar goró e economia poderia
cair eu falei eu vou lá outra vez
aí com 58 dívida aí eu vi aquela
propaganda a família senta na mesa o pai
naval 16 gb filho tá porque ele tem um
bagulho deixe também de família né
ontem eu cheguei só batista como faz pra
mim pra são paulo a falou disputa o são
paulo longe
aí os companheiros catadores que até eu
falava por voltar a são paulo você tá
louco leve gente chamava de bispo caculé
família ganhar dinheiro em casa quem tem
barulho de carro né
esse bagulho e também como quer para
conseguir aí foi que o dia eu ver
cheguei eu batista com ela a visitá lá
não sei que o são paulo chegue também
nessa rua que vai embora pega ela
recebeu em boxes em são paulo eu estava
de chinelo de dedo bermuda que eu
pensava que eles o façam podem sair de
uma rússia caiu dentro de são paulo
mas aí foi de 80 dias e aí minha jornada
para são paulo
oitenta dias de pecado unitel kt
história cá tenho lixão catei na escada
e o fim do caminho e na estrada também
possui um preconceito da sociedade que
têm em geral na questão não é só de
catadores e catadoras na questão de
gênero e em gerar o quanto a esse
sistema
o que a gente vocês são a universidade e
fui para a universidade mas eu fui
aprendendo como em natal
autodidata que eles falaram que assistem
a esse bagulho autodidata aí tá e aí
invento do banheiro aí a ver eu comia
nos física com um bagulho tá cometa uma
forma burra minha barriga rocam
aí o cara não pega uma agulha não te vai
trabalhar vagabundo [ __ ] e tocando
gaúcho tocou para van palavra um projeto
associado e avg estava cansado e ia
dormir no banheiro público aquele banho
porque não estava com medo [ __ ] as
coisas na história a ibm estaria me
acordava de manhã me chutando vai
trabalhavam no poço eu queria descansar
com a minha jornada foi tentar pedir
carona cegonha a vez em casa escondido
naquela cegonha e tal induta e mas na
estrada foram coisas boas que aconteceu
às vezes duas regiões da manhã eu estava
lá naquele shell acho bonito chaves
bairros caminho 11 não aceitava a
chaminé ea escada também o conheci em
minha companheira igual mas cita também
me ajudou e me muitas vezes bancos das
praças mais velho eu cheguei numa cidade
chamada governador valadares
me deram uma garrafa de suco com o pão
português foi politicamente bagulho de
são paulo é são paulo primeiro prato que
eu comi uma cidade e um picadinho por
comigo pra cá não tinha comido um prato
de arroz feijão um pedaço de carne
batata pt mauá já cheguei em são paulo
ela não disse tem que andar mais fraco
ainda é mais ainda
aí eu acabei perdendo a noção do tempo
né tá chegando em são paulo cheguei na
obrigado a pedir ajuda do guarda lá foi
um caso de uma carona até a rodoviária e
lhe deu uma carona e falei pô mandarino
albergue vai mandar um albergue lá tal
albergue saía de manhã e à noite né
e aí no albergue lá eu saí fui fazer o
que eu fazia né
é um ferro velho lá perto do glicério e
aí o o ferro-velho em pessoa acaba o
carrinho dele me agacho carro aí eu só
que eu tinha que vendeu o meu material
pra ele eu tinha dormirá pagava aluguel
pra ele então era tipo uma servidão como
tem muita fé
catar desejo hoje é explorado por uma
servidão do ferro velho já paris então
ele acaba ficando preso
a empregada a gente que tem alta gestão
autonomia e fazer o que a gente gosta
que é a melhor coisa e mostrar para a
sociedade a importância do nosso
trabalho
e aí a as revistas jornais que comecei a
achar que conhecia lei é para aí eu
pegava o jornal o jornal do valor que o
bagulho do valor vai pegar o jornal é a
chama revista national geographic e
comecei a entender os barulhos país na
final grupo a na bahia agora querem esse
bagulho tá nem de jeito país época como
faz painel 80 dia não sei mas a valer
jornal tal tal pra aprender as coisas aí
na escada depois de um tempo eu fui
buscar val a vossa me menina que morena
bonita ela né
e aí o meu primeiro tempo e tal aí eu
conheci ela na escada mas na estrada ela
com 15 anos ela foi esse bagulho que as
meninas estava grávida né e grave com 15
anos ela foi violentada pelo próprio pai
então com 15 anos no meu primeiro filho
dos quatro chan dois são todos filhos e
aí ela confia na frente da casa
só que não podia fazer era naquele
momento aí eu falei vou daqui dois anos
vou te buscar
depois ela foi buscar ela também para
são paulo então eu catei amor na escada
também e aí eu comecei a participar das
coisas me chamaram para participar num
país aí representar o projeto vai ferver
no país chegando pontes bagulhos cana eu
chego no aeroporto tem uma menina bonita
com uma placa lá bispo catanduva por
enquanto não sabe meu nome e meu nome aí
é um bairro que tem nada porque não é
que o cara fala tá achando nada portal e
chegou os outros bagulho louco não
chegou no teu camada taquara o seu bispo
da sua mala do camarada em um show do
tom o catador
minha mãe não mas eu tenho que sair da
chamada que não caia vai me mandar
embora e ele vai voltar a falar do jeito
que você manda embora eu espero
mas aqui o cara né ai paulo caiu em casa
então tudo bem ajudei a carregar as
malas lacão
aí eu vou pro hotel town chego lá no
tempo o cara me dar uma chave para
entrar no hotel faz uma agulha ficha
dele como eu estudei eu aprendia
decorando as coisas aí me deu uma chave
ponto bagulho uma chave quadrada aí eu
chego no apartamento 402 [ __ ] a chave 1
abre o bagulho quadrado por onde por um
lado pro outro e aí o atendimento pela
foto
aí eu me leva a pôr a máquina a sua
carta mas o cartão chave é boa é que a
linha de ferro né
o bagulho o cartão segue ktm que aporta
na portaria e rebentou mas aí o hotel
a palestra do house né tem que descer a
porrada de house e house é onde tem
feito barulho aí tem um monte de barulho
comigo né
nunca vi tanta comida na minha vida né
pode jogar comigo nem com queijo e molho
de queijo e bagulho tem é que todo mundo
tem que ter uma alimentação legal não em
geral mantêm uma café da manhã é legal
pedaço de que ele não pode pagar
aí eu comecei a participar aí eu fui
fazer uma palestra numa cidade aí ainda
estava lá no rio grande do sul porto
alegre o governador a thomas bach eo
prefeito josé fogaça marina da silva
mesmo dentro thomaz bastos da segurança
e pá e aí fala dos catadores e vai
instalar e aí eu comecei profunda
participar na palestra o cara falar que
a cidade de são paulo funcionava o
catador é bem atendido não tem situação
de rua não tem nada mas [ __ ] nem uma
mentira aí eu tenho que admitir o cara
nem o subprefeito de cidade chama andré
matarazzo e 1.4 e mail
aí a e começa a falar e aí eu indiquei
com uma linha
uma menina no palco lá igual você fez
aqui meninas e fala como se falar de um
tal de maxilar e do mate placa não
identificada que acabam maquiné [ __ ]
carvão eu ainda vai fazer uma palestra
aí termina aí eu saio assim de uma
agulha por até o presente eu queria
pedir manhã em essência para vocês aqui
eu posso conhecer o max no campo a amina
dar um cutucão bicho que anda 200 anos
[ __ ] eu não sabia que ele marque aí eu
fui o capital na uff 2010 folha quanto
bagulho que não consegue 10 foi não
conseguir mais lê aí a fama cooperativa
à ativa foi formado em tal e aí eu fui
eu foi o primeiro carro que eu tive que
cantar na cooperativa e o carro faz a
ata bairro de ataque quem chuta é de uma
folha que botou cidade cooperativa
formada em 30 de maio de 2006 presidente
romeu sérgio dias ruins secretário
sérgio da silva bispos conselheiro
sérgio bagulho cooperativa de teatro e
na universidade de salamanca é muito
diferente e aí não sabe escrevendo eu
quero ter uma família e ingênuo ou
escrever na tabela vai mesmo é tem que
ser é oval para isso é não na verdade é
escreva e aí não sabe escrever o evento
a casa até meu filho que fez a água
quando sabem que fui competitivo afirmou
mas nem sabe escrever meu filho que fez
ato e aí vai foi o primeiro contato que
eu fiz que os artistas como a frente tal
como o dano que o primeiro evento em
participar dessa catadores tal e aí eu
não ganhei foi na cooperativa pinto meu
carrinho que naquela época eu puxava um
carrinho de catador tal prova já aí já
comecei a aprender tal questão até botar
um pouco lá aí nessa palestra que eu fui
ainda um bagulho que tinha dele sair
aí eu saí da palestra o cavalo bispo
chega meia hora antes para montar o
bagulho layout lojista muito barulho e
logo que isso é o último disco nunca fiz
isso na minha vida e da uma hora da
manhã duas horas da manhã em duma e vou
lá pra lá
estou hospedado
402 no bairro de lourdes play out
tem que falar porque é gago duas da
manhã
eu não consigo os dois batiam à porta do
apartamento e 404 marina da silva sequer
bispo [ __ ] marina o bagulho vai ficar
louca não sei que eu faço o cara fala o
que tem que fazer e altino e gica entre
quem quer do lado da cama dela pega uma
caneta marina não sei escrever
tá bom que se faz de mãe eu acordo de
manhã sempre naquela mesa que eu vi na
televisão com a família com os filhos
foi uma cooperativa os carrinhos fácil a
organização das coletas netão qualquer
dúvida bicho é bagulho eu tenho é que
foi por universidade é [ __ ] né é o dia
ele é alto e só por cada universidade
nem falo que tenho que montar a
logística eo pib foi o bispo chegar meia
hora antes rumo de colocar aqui arrumar
as mesas bagulho bahia que ficar
apertando pudera mais fácil e aí lá que
eu fui a primeira vez que escutei da
marina da silva a palavra
sustentabilidade
depois de lá dentro dessa palestra
ninguém mais segurou o japa quatro
países já é é a imagem de kaká deixamos
tese mais de tese em todas as
universidades acho que no brasil pede
lá fora as seis universidades é desde o
catador meu melhor no catador e nos
chama catadores que a torneira erros
americanos um par de todas língua e tal
foi o quinto carro que eu participei
tentei ocs que eu ganhei que hoje eu
consigo ver as coisas mais legais a
visão em 3d em 3 a 1 chegou renegava
buscar a me enrolar na bateria mais
vital
vamos lá e aí é o kit né é a idéia do
próprio macaé isso ele não faltar é
trabalho de catadores e catadoras né
josé pode ter vários pimp my carroça
pode ter vários pinto e kombosa seletiva
vários pinto e carrinho elétrico e acho
que nós catadores nós temos um
protagonista dessa história então a
gente tem que se apodera do conhecimento
por isso que eu falo quando a teoria
técnicas andar no mesmo caminho a gente
vai ter um planeta mais justo e
sustentável acho que é isso a gente só
pensa que a teoria é boa
e à prática tal tá aí a gente vai
aprendendo agora só agora estou fazendo
até diagnóstico de resíduo né bagulho no
dia de um diagnóstico
a idéia foi de reformar o meu carro
então essa senhora que eu sempre gostei
né meu carro não pule compromisso sério
tal essa frase a ministra izabella não
gostou e tal mas e aí algumas matérias
que o finep já é o que impediu uma
visibilidade para os catadores de
catadores um desvio de 2 mil vagas
matéria então eu fui
nós fomos persona foi personagem 2000 e
do globo repórter
depois várias televisão agora e ver todo
esse bagulho televisão mídia pra fora e
barulho de descarga foi presa
essa foi a matéria sbc sbt e aí eu vou
participar do cqc da band e aí o marcelo
tas falou bispos e catador de lixo leão
marcelo
o catador de material reciclável por que
eles não existe mas achei interessante
no meio do resíduo conversando e há um
número residual achava uma nota vermelha
uma nota azul bagulho louco né nota
vermelha um atraso que vamos ter aqui e
aí uma jam session foi por marcelo que
achei achei uma coisa legal essa coisa
legal coisas que não são legais e me
achei uma peruca recebe pra você é
certinho
aí o bicho vai precisar também já está
ficando careca também a e tal tem que
ser da band
aí já aí como eu no meu trabalho comecei
a participar de de que a cada
universidade para entender o que é o
risco que ela é ao que é paradigma é
falava no edifício da universidade paga
paradigma conceito é plataforma de
bagulho tá falando tudo aqui me bagulho
mas eu entendi na minha língua e e aí eu
aí comecei a fazer trabalhar e conseguir
aguentar o dinheiro mesmo criando seus
filhos trabalhando 16 horas por dia
trabalho tal tem trabalho que a gente
faz o que gosta melhor e aí consegui
comprar uma kombi com uma kombi que
afasta o evento já tocara agenda do mês
de mês que vem já fechada vou fazer
fé é seguidor de onde houve a balada na
vila são paulo dia 29 agora falando
villa lobos alguma a mãe sair daqui vou
pôr palco da virada cultural ea júlio
pede um monte de bagunça de varzim com
bósnia
aqui foi uma matéria que saiu na folha
de são paulo é tão que ele tá em folhas
thai países várias teses tal aqui tem a
minha página quem quiser me seguir com
borja seletiva ou 6 descartável podem
seguir se tiver alguém tente provar se a
gente faz aí só tem que dar uma olhada
um pouco na minha agenda a imagem dá pra
fazer é muito fácil aqui eu como catador
que eu vou pn é mais de 63 mil do meu
como imagina com um lote cada vez que é
também por isso o cara tem que sempre
quando ele foi pensado que coleta
seletiva gestão de rígido ele imaginar
que tem um cara ali que cuida do bairro
direito que é o cara que a idéia de
fazer a cadeia justa não a gente criar
uma cadeia em vista que tem no mercado
e aí é k t no ventre da minha mãe
catei na estrada catei na rua catão do
amor da minha companheira minha família
catanho de meus amigos conhecimento e
também aprendi muito com seus amigos
bagulho sociólogo da universidade e o
caso português é português mas não gosto
de chamar de problema dele ele foi
bagulho da universidade sociólogo a
conhecer é ex tenistas bagulho
universidade de pessoas tudo aí tá e aí
também esse foi o catarinense meu amigo
e é com vocês
infelizmente a sociedade o que você acha
que a fala de todo mundo aí a sociedade
hoje ela está consumindo as ilan da
mente não consumindo com recentemente
porque ela acaba a gente só vê embalagem
pelo pela boniteza pelo projeto
a gente tem que pensar que que tem
oceano com um monte de residência
justine e até lá na lua uma vez kaká e
infelizmente cada brasileiro está
consumindo um time dirigido por isso é
péssimo cidade de são paulo 11 milhões
de habitantes são quase 20 toneladas de
resíduos por dia onde vai pagar isso e
as pessoas têm que começar
a escudar do meio ambiente não vai ter
mas nem meio até o fim e aí vi que as
pessoas têm que valorizar o trabalho
nosso de catadores de catadores que é
com dificuldade com o carrinho com essas
com borges ou com a chapa forma reta o
japão boj a seletiva ela já ela já
formou quatro coletivo de catadores que
consegue fazer a gestão de resíduo do
servente ea ideia que dê jeito que a
gente está andando
vai acontecer o que aconteceu aqui o
bispo lá na lua ou em marte khatami
resíduo já estou acatando ela a seguir
mantendo agulha reciclagem voltar lá
capello já residem e aí por isso vocês
jovens meninos e as meninas que todos
aqui são os meninos de mim eu estou já
com barros 60 anos né
mas ainda tenho um gás ainda eu acho que
consigo chegar aos 100
tomara né caiu guetta mas não é porque a
gente não cuidar do planeta por isso tem
de valorizar agora ela faz um tempão um
carrinho de um catador de uma carta de e
isso é legal que dá visibilidade para
nosso trabalho que é é a cidade cinza
cidade escura e o grafite como andamos
juntos já que depois de conhecer uma
porrada de artista e tal isso é legal
mostra um trabalho até um bagulho tá
falando minuto 89
e aí quando ele pára aí posso
parabenizar roma e aí deve beber porque
a pessoa tem que fazer o trabalho de
catadora da catadora quer mais de 50
anos nós fazemos esse trabalho e muitas
vezes ainda no chão reconhecido pela
sociedade uma grande parte reconhece mas
muito imagina que tudo é lixo e mais
lixo não existe e é composta a seletiva
até quem quiser chamar a gente tem aí eu
também vou começar a pensar na capital
da plataforma do barulho a compra da
seletiva da plataforma de bug é é quem a
questão da beleza valeu obrigado